a radio audience has returned and also
returning here on the rich eisen show
is uh one of our favorites he knows so
much and i just love the way our
conversations go i always
am smarter for it when brian winhorst of
espn calls into the program how are you
brian
hi rich how are you doing i'm fine how
long have you been in the bubble in
orlando
i have not been there i'm not i'm not
planning on going you're not at
you're not there okay i thought you'd
call in there okay i just
uh rich i just couldn't i've got a
two-year-old and um i got it
i just couldn't do it and you know these
um these players i really
uh i i feel it i i feel what
you know they didn't really have a
choice so those of us who had a choice
were fortunate
right okay so um how much
uh do you think the bubble is affecting
what we're seeing
just in in everything from the from the
play to
the the sense of uh being removed
uh from the real world that the players
led to
what happened this past week how much do
you think that is playing into
everything
from what you're hearing brian everybody
like everybody i talk to in the bubble
rich
i mean i talk to people in there i talk
to multiple people every single day
and they all say you have no idea how
hard this
is and they say that
not saying that they're in a prison
they're not saying that this is a
hardship of their life
they're just talking about the challenge
that they that is that is now
a part of this whole thing having said
that i have seen
it have no material effect on the
quality of the games
in fact one of the things that i thought
for sure was going to happen
is that we would see teams go into punt
formation
and just sort of give up starting in
those seating games
and then when they got behind in series
and we just
haven't seen that we have seen
incredible competition on the court
the play itself has not shown
any ill effects from the
the environment and you know doc rivers
has said that he actually thinks
that it's helped players to have that
sort of
tv studio set up so that they don't have
the deep shooting backgrounds he thinks
they shoot better
the other thing that's happening is
officials are calling more fouls
which is frustrating but is actually
creating more scoring
um which is what people want anyway and
it gives teams a chance to get back in
games
and i think they're calling more fouls
because they can hear better
i think they hear contact more than they
do i don't know that's just my theory
and so while i do think it's difficult
for them i think the game has benefited
brian windhorst here on the rich eisen
show what is at stake
for the houston rockets in this series
well it's a lot at stake for their
organization i think
you know i don't know if mike d'antoni
is under pressure because
he doesn't have to prove anything he's
he will continue to coach in this league
if he wants to
but you know if they get knocked out in
this round there's a chance that he's
going
to be told you know to move on there's
pressure on daryl mori
the general manager who i don't think it
was his burning desire to trade
chris paul for russell westbrook but he
made the trade
and then he doubled down going small and
fast at mid-season
and more you know there have been
general managers fired for more than
that um
i think james harden who has had
opportunity after opportunity over the
last three years
and has never been able to exceed them
in the postseason they've
had just things swings things flip
through their fingers
i think everybody has a little bit of it
and um
and yet they are the underdogs they're
the significant underdogs and and i
think they are
the team that will have potential
significant changes if they don't win
this series
why is d'antoni not under contract past
potentially this series i mean what what
what gives
there i think there's a number of
different reasons i think the reason he
didn't sign the extension was he didn't
want a one-year extension
in addition to whatever the money was i
think he was like look i'll take a
three-year extension thank you very much
and i think that's why he didn't sign it
as for why the um
as for why the rockets didn't feel the
need to do it
i i don't fully understand it i i don't
understand why they haven't negotiated
an extension with him
in the last two days he is a perfect
coach for the wed the way they want to
play and there is a reason why
tillman fertility does not want to do it
only he knows why maybe it will present
itself to us
maybe it won't but um if they change
coaches maybe they will get a coach
who's successful and takes them even
further than d'antoni but
um i don't see it's so hard to find a
good coach
rich um especially one where
the personnel fits your vision and
that's one of the things that happens
all the time you bring in a coach and it
takes either two years to get the
players he wants or he
fails and he complains that they don't
get the players he wants this is the
project
this is a you know a three or four year
project to get the players that he wants
this is what teams want
to match their coach and their style
with their talent
um i don't see why you undo it but um i
can't speak for
a lot of things that happened in the nba
and then the last one on this subject of
the rockets is russell westbrook
uh was he rushed back too soon because
he he
he looked occasionally dreadful as we
know at the end of game six game seven
was a little bit better but he just
doesn't look he does seem to have the
burst but he just he's not finishing and
it's not crisp let's put it that way at
all well that's a huge injury
to your to you know you have an injury
to your thigh a thigh muscle
i mean you know we saw i mean look no
injury is the same but one of the things
i learned
is uh you know every injury is different
with every player but
you look at a guy like patrick beverly
he had a calf injury right
and he missed six games um well
obviously the thigh muscles
much bigger and stronger and and they
would take longer to heal and and
westbrook came back quicker than that
you know
the injury happened after he returned
before so
um you know i'm sure he's pushing it
because it's the playoffs uh
the thing about westbrook is is that
historically you know he's had some
injuries
in his career including a number of knee
surgeries and he has always
come flying out of the gate when he's
come back from injuries it's one of the
remarkable things about his career is
the way he comes back from injuries so
i think part of it is he just feels like
he's a guy who can who can deal with
more than the average player and
we'll see whether that actually plays
out or not um there's still time here
he's still getting
theoretically better every day and
meanwhile i mean just the western
conference playoffs with the lakers
having this layoff now
coming in against the rockets the
clippers got beverly back
and and it appears everybody is is
healthy and moving forward uh what's
that what's the deal with
uh morris and and his uh i guess
imminent birth of a child
or imminent um suspension because of
what happened
with luca what's going on with him in
the clippers opportunity
that's right there in front of them
right here well he's not imminently
being suspended
you know i it was i don't know what's
going on with his uh
with his child but um in the draymond
green
you know it's almost like a draymond
green rule remember
draymond green did not get suspended for
that finals game because he hit lebron
in that game
he got suspended for accumulation of
flagrant
foul points okay so
you you know i don't know if you want me
to bore you with the system but
long story short okay he gets either two
more flagrant ones or one more flagrant
two it's a suspension
i'd like to point out they've just
started round two um
and you know marcus morris is an
important player for them
so anything that would cause him to miss
a game whether it was the birth of a
child or
um you know hitting an outside or you
know getting us the the
point limit would be hurt from the
clippers even last night
he hit five or six threes in that game
he's devastating
when he's able to uh stretch the floor
like that he's a very rugged defender
they're going to want him
for every game of a possible lakers
series so it's one of those things
that's out there there's so many things
that happened during the course of a
playoff run
um some of them are predictable some of
them are not but i mean i'll tell you
one thing i am
eyes wide awake two flagrant foul points
for marcus morris and
counting keep an eye on that i will
definitely keep an eye on that and
again it's a double header on espn
tonight starting with
the heat and the bucks why are the bucks
uh um
in trouble of falling into an 03 hole
brian
rich this reminds me so much of the 2009
cavaliers now maybe it's because i was
covering that team
but to take you back uh that was a 66
win
cavs regular season team lebron james
was the mvp
of the league his first mvp award um
they were uh
a team that is you know much like the
bucks and that they
didn't really have a huge second star
although chris middleton is better than
anything that the cavs had back then
but they had a blend of young players
and veteran players delante
west mo williams ben wallace wally
zerbiak
and all these shooters it was a team
that you know they started the season
one and two
and i think they pretty much rested
lebron down the stretch and i think they
lost a couple of games
uh in the last week of the season and
other than that they were like
65 and eight okay they were like
incredibly juggernaut team but they were
not built for the playoffs and they were
not a title team
and that showed up in the postseason
when they played the orlando magic the
orlando magic
had owned them during the regular season
much like the miami heat
felt really comfortable in their matchup
with the bucks and
while lebron was great and he was great
in the series that they lost
it was clear that he didn't necessarily
know how to
lead a team you know in in under under
duress like that now i would argue that
lebron leading underdog teams i mean he
is he has won
as um as an underdog you know with a
lower seed i don't
ever call him an underdog but he has won
repeatedly with the lower seat
um he didn't learn how to do that he
hadn't didn't know how to do it yet and
so
and at that time that was when the clock
was starting to tick on his free agency
and if you watch the heat bucks games
during the regular season just as if you
would watch the
magic cavs games as i did during the
2009 season
you would know that this was going to be
a troublesome series for milwaukee and
yes mike buttonholder has made
some frustrating decisions if you're a
bucks fan
sitting giannis playing in fewer minutes
in game two than game one
um you know not putting your best
defensive players
um you know on jimmy butler down the
stretch of uh
of game one you know i wouldn't you know
eric's
and by the way back in that series stan
van gundy out coach mike brown
even though mike brown was the coach of
the year um that you know right now mike
buttonholder is getting out coached by
eric's bolster so
i look at the bucks and i see tremendous
team with a great system but i don't see
title team and
during the course of the season this is
what everybody in the league i talked to
said yes the bucks are on pace for 70
wins yes they've got a great defense but
they don't scare us
and i would say that on radio shows or
podcasts or i would write it
and people in milwaukee would get
frustrated with me and um
so this is you know i i'm not saying
here i was like oh they're going to get
knocked out in the second round
but this is kind of the personification
of what we watched for a long time
and i'm mistaking the game's on tnt to
start and the espn has lakers rockets
what did you make of richard jefferson's
twitter igniting
statement that giannis is more of a
pippen than a jordan meaning
he's not the uh you know
goat type player who can take a team on
his shoulders
himself the alpha male and that he's
more of a
i guess um robin not the batman what do
you think
well um i disagree with richard on this
um
you know there are certain players you
learn that about during their careers
like i remember
coming to that conclusion about chris
bosh as great of a player as he was in
toronto
it was clear that he was not he was
probably not going to
have a great career if he was the best
player on the team he needed to go
somewhere where he wasn't the best
i think giannis can win you games with
his with his play because he is
an ace defensive player and he's a beast
offensive player i think what richard is
saying is that
he i think a better way to say it is he
is not a complete player yet
um and you know he has to develop his
game a little bit he has to learn some
changeouts because right now um when
when the pressure gets on he only knows
one thing to do
he grabs the ball puts his head down and
barrels to the hoop
and everybody in the league knows it and
so they get in his way and try to take
charges um and
it's it's again not unlike lebron lebron
would play iso basketball and be afraid
to pass to his teammates back in 2008-9
so
you know i know that they're not the
same player but i would
i would say to you if you if you want to
say that giannis is not a complete
player now then
you should probably go back to 2009 take
lebron's mvp award and say you're not
he wasn't a complete player because he
wasn't the lebron in 2012
that won the title was holding the
trophy for the first time was not to
lebron in 2009 and the honest is 25.
so i i mean um uh
i would just say to richard let's have
this conversation in three years what
team is giannis on in three years
this is going to be so fascinating rich
because
the super max was designed
from the ground up for this exact moment
the same situation kevin durant was in
which is why they created the super max
seven year player in a small market
pay him more money than he could
possibly imagine make it
so so heavily weighted on the financial
cost of leaving that the player feels
uh financial obligation to stay if
giannis signs it
the system would have worked by the
owner's standards if he doesn't sign it
you might as well take the system and
throw it in lake michigan
uh you really just take it out of the
cba just take it right out because it's
because it's not working
and to talk to people in milwaukee they
think it's lunacy
they say no everything that this guy is
doing
he says where he's staying this is not
his personality
he is aligned with coach buttenholzer he
is building his dream home
um you know this is not who he is he is
not like lebron he is not like durant
he is a different guy who grew and
basically grew up as an
you know became an american basically in
milwaukee this is his
american hometown they could go on and
on and scold you all along the way
and i would just say that that could be
true and
the rules are in are in effect but i
would
find it hard pressed for any player
or any agent or any you know
non-objective third party forget the
bucks fans
to look at this situation and say
giannis now is when you want to sign
when you can get the same contract in a
year
and have more flexibility so we're going
to learn a lot about giannis
about the cba system and about the
future of the nba
when that contract is offered to him
whenever the off-season is
deemed to start whether it's october
november whatever brian windhorst here
on the rich eisen show last one for you
sir you mentioned durant
durant coming off from injury with kyrie
irving
in new york city just as the knicks
continue to keep shooting themselves in
the
dolan foot or whatever you want to call
it
is one of the most plum coaching jobs
i think the nba could offer up right now
and it goes to steve nash where did that
come from by the way you know it's 25
years ago this week that the
heat completed their transaction to hire
pat riley one million dollars in a first
round pick what do you think would
happen with the knicks if they kept that
riley and made him team president oh
please
don't even get me started man i mean
think about that
please i would have been amazing
i just think about that um you want to
talk about great trades in nba history
how about that one
uh advantage heat um i actually think
this is one of the most challenging jobs
out there
um and i understand why people want the
job because if you're going to be a head
coach
you don't want to take you know ideally
you don't want to take a team from 17
wins and try to get them to 37
over two years like you know you want to
take a team
from 40 wins and take them to 58 and try
to win a title you
you want to play for the whole thing
that's what you want
so i can understand why steve nash would
take this but i think it's an incredibly
difficult situation
number one the personalities there are
just challenging
uh it's not that i think that kyrie and
duran are bad fit i think they're a
great fit
uh basketball wise but they're
challenging and
again it's not because they're petulant
or because they're subversive
it's because i've watched them with
their you know they
they get into moves they they get into
social media things they say get into
issues with teammates um
and the put these two together i just
think it's gonna be
it's gonna take an incredible um
steadying hand to do it i mean phil
jackson
won 11 championships because he was able
to manage
complex personalities and star players
yeah the triangle was awesome and the
triangle did help get a lot of baskets
but
he managed you know michael jordan with
dennis rodman
right you know he he negotiated dennis
rodman to go to vegas
nice you know what's more important
getting a couple of baskets in the
triangle or
keeping michael jordan from ringing
dennis rodman's neck
you know what's more important getting
kobe and shaq to play together
or you know you know getting robert dory
open on the back side i mean
i know once i know getting the shot
isn't not important but
that's the thing for steve nash the
challenge is going to be to get those
two guys together and
one of the most fascinating things i've
seen
in the last five years in the nba is
that kevin durant
chose to get into a marriage with kyrie
irving
i just didn't see that as something that
durant would want
um and kyrie did the sales job you know
to me durant would want to be with a guy
like kawhi who
can play sort of opposite on the wing
from him and is no drama
and doesn't really need much oil
can be totally fine and kawhi called him
he kawhi called them after they went up
with the raptors last year and said hey
you want to play together
but he was already betrothed to kyrie
kyrie got in
got in and got in with him and you know
kyrie is basically told two teams i
don't want to be with you anymore
and so now you're i mean it's almost
like kind of getting in for somebody
with their third marriage okay the first
one was arranged he didn't get to
choose lebron lebron and the cavs chose
him
but it's it's worrisome it's worrisome
to keep that together
now you could play this back in in 12
months and say boy were you a fool after
they win 63 games and go to the finals
i admit that that's possible but i just
think it's a huge hurdle
and any coach i don't care if it was
greg popovich
was going to have their hands full
dealing with that so i will be watching
and it'll be a heck of a soap opera is
my prediction brian
love our chats i say that every single
time i mean it this is just
uh i i i love it and thank you once
again for calling the show and we'll
call you again real soon
enjoy that baby enjoy your holiday
weekend thank you that's brian windhorst
of espn which will have tonight's lakers
rockets game one hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here